Merci beaucoup.
Voilà, j'aimerais vous raconter une histoire.
Lorsque j'ai débarqué de l'avion,
après un long voyage depuis l'ouest de l'Angleterre,
mon ordinateur, mon bien-aimé ordinateur portable,
était devenu incontrôlable,
et il avait -- oh! -- un peu comme cela! --
et l'affichage --
bref, il était complètement planté.
Et je suis allé voir les informaticiens d'ici
et un type sympa a réparé mon ordinateur,
et puis il m'a demandé, "Que faites-vous ici?"
et je lui ai répondu "Je joue du violoncelle et je chante aussi un peu,"
et il m'a dit "Oh! Il m'arrive aussi de jouer du violoncelle."
Et je lui ai dit, "Ah oui, vraiment?"
Quoi qu'il en soit, vous allez vous régaler,
parce qu'il est fantastique, et il se nomme Mark.
(Applaudissements)
Je suis aussi accompagnée par mon complice, Thomas Dolby.
Cette chanson s'appelle "Plus loin que le Soleil."
(Musique)